[Music]
before you pay is he detective Pikachu
revisit the first time he quick attacked
your wallet for a film that used to
delight your inner child and now we'll
just embarrass your outer adult Pokemon
the first movie you two strikes back
anymore titles their movie wanna throw
an electric Boogaloo in for good measure
no okay you got swept up in the Polka
mania of the late 90s and if you didn't
this probably ain't for you chief
because they're not wasting any time
explaining what this place is who these
people are or why that cat is a Brooklyn
accent to be fair not even the super
fans are sure about that one so if you
need a crash course on all things poke a
it's about child Runaways who make their
animals think be each other unconscious
but don't worry they like it allegedly
be a sh an idiot who's constantly on the
verge of death
[Applause]
misty an idiot who's constantly nagging
and frog an idiot who's constantly horny
she's cute they just keep getting more
beautiful every time I see him she's
really small but really pretty together
with an adorable merchandising
opportunity this not so Elite Four will
bumble into a secret fighting tournament
slash world domination plot that will
make everyone say but nothing can
prepare them for view to a psychic claw
whose week to bug types and existential
crises he's got a plan to liberate
Pokemon from their human masters that
sounds pretty reasonable actually until
he starts killing everyone
one he gets from siding with a villain
who's in the right got a kill oh ma try
not to hurt yourself in the confusion
because the franchise all about Pokemon
fights comes out hard against Pokemon
fights because when they're beating each
other up to see who's the strongest it's
fine but when they're beating each other
up to settle who's the strongest once
and for all
it's suddenly not fine like this now I
can see how horrible fighting really is
I've got one word for you movie so
buckle up for yet another crappy video
game movie based on a great video game
franchise that may not be the best
introduction to Pokemon anime or even
Pokemon anime but the soundtrack is a
perfect crash course in early 2000s pop
music Britney Christina NSYNC and 98
degrees wow I should really just watch
spirited away instead story - casual
RepA - no one writes for free I like
jords they're tiny and difficult to wear
brockhard the alchemax Garfield and
friends
and Jordan peels eyes
[Music]
Pokemon the first movie you saw when you
were eight I wonder if the subversion
makes more sense nope
to fit even more Game of Thrones into
your eyeballs click the box to watch our
after-show watching Thrones or if you
need to get caught up before the game
concludes check out our Kremen of the
complete series I Know Who I am I'm the
dude playing the two disguised as
another dude everything the light
touches is our kingdom